when we get started I guess it is the
last day right so this is the home
straight up contractor the home stretch
okay so the home this the home is right
this is a home run
so sherry Lee will be filling these up
it just up the hill yeah we're telling
us about using randomized algorithms in
various sort of scientific computing
type problems in certain instructions of
the famous agent self-operated okay
thank you
and everybody here okay so I'm up the
hill very local and I have several
collaborators work on this very good and
in particular for this particular talk
is Chris Coleman he is still finishing
PhD from Santa Barbara and he came with
us for two summers worked quite a bit on
this so they do also they do quite a bit
a theoretical work which I want to show
but also we want to you know for this
conference I want to talk to people and
get some advice in terms of for using
randomization we just started doing this
recently and the majority of the the
worker currently is fund is funded by
the excess scale computing project and
if you don't know we do EE is the
planning to have the excess scale
machine available either end of twenty
twenty twenty-one so in that two to
three years and obviously a lot of
investment it needs to be you know
looking at hardware software etc but it
one important component is the scaleable
algorithm that's where you know we
fitted here and all these randomization
algorithms it's a very very good so the
the talk is meaning about a hierarchical
matrix and it's mathematical foundation
is a very similar to faster multiple fmm
discovered more than thirty years ago
and in the fmm term
you are talking about the particles so
we talk about a near field of our field
the far field you can do some
aggregation approximation but in if you
put this in the matrix form you are
talking about
diagonal close to diagonal which is a
near field and then off diagonal far
away which is the far field so it's a
very similar kind of concept so in the
matrix form on the right side this
figure here for the off diagonal block
and very often you can even though it
looks a tense but you can use some
low-rank approximation to approximate it
very well so once you put it into the
algebraic matrix form it's actually very
powerful you can do matrix
multiplication of course you can do
factorization you can do a version so
it's that's where the power comes and
then the few the hierarchical matrix are
in recent years have been very active
for area so people invented the
different formats and do the different
operations so here I just gave you two
examples one is on the left is the the H
matrix was invented to almost 20 years
ago by a hack Bush their group so here
you do heretical partitioning the
diagonal blocker you keep it as dense
since they cannot be approximated well
but then you look at with the off
diagonal block depending on your matrix
you have the flexibility whether you
want to do the compressive a
representation here this one if it's it
doesn't allow you to compress then you
represent yourself dense block up and
then the green ones you know you can
compress so it's a very flexible format
but then on the other hand if you want
to do the matrix factorization with this
format it's not so easy it's actually
more expensive on the right side here is
the hierarchical HSS it's the
hierarchical semi separable matrix it's
discovered more recently but almost
tanked I think more than ten years now
was started here minggu was involved a
very much and
he's a former student attending SIA
right now he says still actively working
on this so this one has a slightly nicer
structure so you can you still have a
hierarchical partition and then the
blocks you look at to the block of
organized octagonal block organized in a
hierarchical way and also you organize
your bases you can compute it in a
hierarchical nested basis so in this
slightly better structured way you
actually can do the factorization
inversion it's a much faster than this
so I'll show you some result okay about
these HSS it's really starting you have
to do the partitioning so they in the
high post their term and they use block
cluster tree cluster tree block cluster
tree so in the matrix term you say for
example you decide to the bottom level
like a block size 100 or something and
then this is your bottom level of
diagonal block the off diagonal block
could you do something and then every
time you merge pairwise merge of the off
diagonal block so pairwise merge into
the next level of diagonal blockers so
then you get this cluster tree when the
custer tree is organized the way you do
this partition both row wise and column
wise then it's the block structure so
this tree is the side wise okay and then
the HSS that one thing is to look at
these off diagonal block in a nested way
so so here for example this is your
bottom level off diagonal block or you
did the SVD type type of compression
that you want you to here right and then
when you move to merge into the next
level you can computer this SVD again
from scratch but that's not what that
doesn't save you a lot of work so what
in this case you do is that you you city
or what you have already computed from
the children through children here and
at the parent you only need to get a
small this orthogonal basis
the representation while you multiply
them out it's the you know mathematical
way as the true representation so so you
can multiply them out as a big new
vector but you can see that you're with
this so you actually save storage also
save for operation but then everything
when you do operation you need to follow
this HSS tree to do the sweep from
bottom to up and top to bottom so that's
the HSS in a nutshell and as I said you
can do factorization and because in HSS
we have a lot of these unitary matrices
so we do a lot of little uniform
transformation to transform into the L
matrix and in particular here we call
this ulv factorization so this is your a
matrix already compressor in HSS right
and then you do all these little
orthogonal transformation and some
permutation here and in the end that
turns into this L matrix so once you
have this factorization the orthogonal
matrix and L now you can do the salt so
that's the factorization okay so what I
really want to get into is this the
compression kernel which is critical for
all these heretical low-rank
approximation and only recently we
started to looking at using
randomization before our first version
of the code was using traditional
rereading QR and they turns out to be
not so great for it's actually very
difficult to do when we embed this
scheme into the sparse sparse lyrics
over like a multi-front Oh solver
so then essentially we have to redo you
know is we do a lot of the software and
this run my sampling is very familiar to
all of you I think that's what this
workshop is about so I would do very
quickly and so essentially for any
matrix a suppose you know the target
rank and then you take this random
matrix Omega with a slightly over
sampling the column dimension
and then multiply get the sample matrix
you get to this Q is the orthogonal
basis of this sample matrix and turns
out this secure will be a good
approximation of the color base itself
for a matrix okay and then Joe isn't
here it's a good this is a very good as
I am review paper a lot of different
aspects about randomization applied to
numerical linear algebra so it's a
highly recommended for reading so in
this paper if you read paper you can see
that there are different ways to
quantify this approximation quality so
the for example on average expected
value of this is given by this quantity
this just says that if you do SVD for a
for example you drop the you just take
the leading hey singular vectors that
your approximation is the best which is
the the next singular value but with
this randomized sampling and then you
get a something slightly worse than the
optimal but then the factor this the
factor is not so big is related to the
matrix dimension and the probabilistic
way you can say that with very high
probability related to P that's why this
P doesn't need to be very big with high
probability then you get error bound is
bounded by this so that's a very nice
tool and the nice thing about this
example is you can build the solver
actually it's a matrix free because all
we need is to get to the sample matrix
multiplied here we don't need to access
matrix essentially so that's a very nice
thing very useful for many applications
and another thing I do it already it's
very good for embedding this in smart
frontal solver simplify a lot of things
you as opposed to just a plain
you are rather revealing QR give you
something like approximate these this
guy we use we didn't try the strong one
strong one could give you I think a
better pound you know more guarantee we
use the only the the column cavities
that's that works already yeah okay so
so then to do this RS put in the contact
self to do HSS compression is basically
you have all you can think about you
have a pre-processing step which is the
sampling let's say suppose your matrix
is not symmetric and what you do is you
need to sample both the column space and
also the row space the transpose we
multiply them together this is a
separator pre-processing step and then
because we are only doing the
compression for the off diagonal block
so for each of these sample matrix it's
represented in this way so you have to
subtract the about the diagonal block in
order to get to this the Henkel block
which is the off diagonal one so it's
just a little bit of manipulation where
you go do the compression along the HSS
tree okay so the practical issue is
actually we you know get the code but
then there are a lot of problems when we
get the people to use the software so
one is we don't know the wrong color and
we are we want to epsilon wrong cuz
people usually want to certain tolerance
right you know the error and then
sometimes in the internal blocks the
singular spectrum may not be decay as
you like and something is expensive so I
will mention some of the or a solution
for you know these issues so the first
the solution is we want to get these
adaptive yet sampling but adaptive scan
assembly it's easy to say but then the
question is you need a good error
estimation to stop your adapt ation and
that's something Chris comment did a lot
of work and then sampling there's a you
know if you just do the matrix market
it's order n square operation he doesn't
you know it's very expensive so there
are some tricks and in fact I want to
talk to people about a DS so adaptive
for sampling is you start with you know
s1 for example you say I don't know the
run correct
I will start with a hundred then every
time I increment so when you you do this
as one to do the QR to get the basis and
then when your error is is too large
then you get a add more samples to put
into this space but you need to do
orthogonalization with being this cute
the new Q and Earth organized
orthogonalize it against the previous
one so the procedure is very simple the
question is what's the error so remember
in the HSS case what we do is we do the
sampling beforehand so you already have
this sample matrix and then you do
compression along the HSS tree right so
the the issue is you don't know whether
the samples are enough but you
discovered you know in the middle of
this tree that means in the middle one
of the you know octagonal block here you
discovered that these samples number of
samples you use this not enough and one
way to overcome this problem is you say
I scratch everything I start add more
samples start from scratch but that
means you're these guys they are already
good that work is lost so it's not very
good so what we do is at this node this
is the partially compressed the node or
the node of below that are already
compressed we don't want to redo this
compression so what we do here is we try
to expand spaces the samples only on at
this node
so the one question is here we don't
have the matrix a we only have the
example matrix and then we need to stop
this adaptation having some a good
stocking criteria so we need to
establish a certain kind of relationship
between the error between the a norm and
the sample matrix the norm and that's a
you know it could be actually derived or
very easily from this relation so if you
write your matrix a in the singular
value case suppose you drop those and
then you have for define another
variable kasi which is the B transpose
times X then the Casilla is also a
Gaussian random vector so here at my
axis from normal distribution cost so
then I exit the two norm can be written
in this way so it's just that the sum of
the singular values does the square plus
this the passive square okay so this
casillas actually it's the Chi square
with the mean is what the Chi square
degree one so then you can write down
this expected value of this ax to norm
is just a sigma one you know square plus
this because the expected value of for
Percy is the one so then that's related
to the a norm of Frobenius norm so you
can see that with this sample matrix
sample vector the norm is related to the
matrix a a itself so that's the relation
we need in order to stop the adaptation
and if you have for these uncle vectors
then you expected value is just a d
times e this guy okay
so then with this we can have a good
stopping criteria so when you expand
into the new as tool here and what you
do is you look at the sample the F norm
of this in the absolute - case just that
divided by square root of P if this one
is smaller than that and this will be
approximately smaller than that and
similarly you can use this sample as to
this new sample to do the relative flow
criteria and the cost is very small it's
just the one reduction of the sample
vector no okay so there is some
technical details here so we did
experimental with this using this
parameterize the matrix so here in this
matrix I have UV they are orthogonal
matrices with a predefined iraq okay and
then P diagonal is actually control how
the singular values are the K so this K
in this case is they K very nicely
relative to this rank R and the
experiment I did here is for the road
imagine this here I'm changing the
accuracy of the tolerance from large to
small and for the column dimension I'm
changing the relative tolerance so we
have two tolerance so this example is we
initial d the random vector is a 16
every time we add a 16 so we just keep
adapting so that in table each entry I
have two values the one is the computer
- HSS to encode or no one is random some
host used so as you can see that with
this is a very nice symmetric so you
know well decayed then your computed the
random are the vectors you use actually
never exceed the actual rug so it's
usually very nice even when you ask for
very high accuracy challenge early does
that mean you're using twice as enough
oh yeah that's a very good point yes we
do twice actually yeah that's a similar
to the twice is enough but that's a very
good point
and then we change this parameterised
the matrix so that diagonal is one
there's no clear decay and the same
experiment but then you can see that the
only difference everything if you're you
don't ask for very high accuracy
everything is still look where works
very well except at the lower right
corner here when you ask for very very
high accuracy then you need to the code
needs to compute a lot more samples in
order to get that level but that's
really is you know very the case that
you really really need to want to a very
high accuracy so then for this same
parameterize the matrix it's a bit
larger and giving you just the one to
see some constitutional caster or for
the activity so that they mention is the
60,000 and then it has a decay of the
singular values and then this is wrong
on the one thousand processes so in the
table here the experiment hits we're
starting with the 128 the random samples
the increment is 64 in a table I gave
you three columns of tier time and the
rancor etc so the first column is since
for this matrix are no the rank so it
came precisely the number four samples
this is the fastest that possible
the middle one is out at activity then
the last one is suppose you don't have
this adaptive strategy now you can you
you can as I said before you can go back
and you know scratch everything and then
add some written redo everything so you
can see that at the compression in this
case we did adaptation 17 times and for
the hard way started this experimenter
there's a four okay so you can see that
even with the 17 times adaptation the
time is not so much more it's just
slightly more than the the fastest are
possible and it's much much faster than
if you restart from scratch
okay so let's see the the one last thing
I want to mention is this sampling
somebody is the pre-processing so in
fact it for a lot of cases if you just
do the matrix vector multiplication to
do the sampling it's actually very
expensive so the sampling costs the
dominant dominance so it's like a order
of art and square RS if it's the target
of rank and in practice it can be 80% of
the wrong time so that's not very good
and there are some ways to do this you
can use some structured matrix for
example had no matrix FFT or if the
matrix is topless you can do FFT or you
can do so so those things that we
haven't tried but what we have tried is
to use the H matrix format to help
somebody so I'll give you one example
here so this is the example of using
kernel Ridge regression to do the
classification in the data science so
the kernel matrix we are using is the
Gaussian matrix and if you're you know
if you know the kernel regression method
so the internally you need to solve in
the while you build the model to do the
training you need to solve this linear
system k plus regularize the term and
here we use our faster hssh matrix
technique to do this so what I want to
show you is here again I have two data
set up from a new CI one is the SUSE is
4.5 million the dimensional feature
space is a tree so it's relatively easy
it's a low dimension problem and another
one is a cough type it's half a minute
the data points and the dimension is a
higher it's a 50 for usually higher
dimensional problems is harder and in
the experiments here we did a tooth for
the two dataset we vary the number of
processes so one is 32 processes here
one is a five
so you can see that what we do here is
we use the H matrix which is easier to
construct you know faster to construct
but even with the 512 4 processes it
takes a still taker 18 seconds unit for
construction and then we use this
approximate H matrix to do the sampling
then to help this HSS construction so
that's already faster than if you do the
traditional matrix vector multiplication
but still the sampling is still like 10
minutes compared to dominate suit every
everything else so once you have the
compression then the factors you are
without translation has solved are
pretty much instant very very fast so
there's a still issue of for how to you
know in improve the speed of sampling
that's something you know we still need
to look into so just to give you a
couple four charts about a scalability
of the current solver and this is the
the example two examples so one is from
quantum chemistry it's actually a
topless matrix the diagonal is defined
like this of diagonal is defined like
that it's constant turbulence and
another one is our this parameter matrix
so we run up to 4000 cores so for the
quantum chemistry matrix because the run
case is small is like in under 100 the
HSS rank and then it gets very good
scalability but for this matrix of rank
R it's relatively big so it's a skills
worse and we embedded this technology
into the sparse market front row solver
into to all the dense
franco matrix and this is the example of
sparse scalability up to 6000 processes
so we have this sparse matrix dimension
is 1.5 million so in sparse matrix
usually there are you know different
steps there's a symbolic factorization
the numerical factorization solution etc
so the numerical factorization
construction is relatively skating well
but at the other faces we
still need to work on the strong
scalability okay and then this is just
the pointer to the software it's there's
a two components advanced component a
sparse component and the Pens component
that you can represent either have a
explicit matrix input or if it's matrix
free scenario you can we have an
interface for data also and one thing I
want to point out is really just for a
lot of our papers I didn't listed them
here but it if you go to this the
website we have all the published papers
there so you can get them up here
so these after we introduce this
randomized sampling it helps a lot but I
think there's still a lot of things
needs to be investigated in terms of the
numerix and also the sub how to reduce
the sampling cost is still a big issue
and then because this kind of
factorization is approximated they work
very well for elliptic pde but for some
other applications which at best I think
we can use this as a preconditioning so
we have some result hood for the
preconditioning and the nice thing about
this with this hierarchical way of food
you know tree structure even in a sparse
case the multi from luxury now you it's
more parallelizable compared to
contradiction or iru the preconditioning
and it's a quite robust compared to IOU
it is good so but they're not hopeful
parallel computing issues that listed
them here that's why I will working okay
thank you
[Applause]
all right quick questions in a parallel
s/he would make sure that we get the
time so the next thing set up properly
so in parallel we don't want to make
sure the devilish yeah for the two weeks
um but sherry
does that mean you pretend you represent
the Carter matrix as an HSG thanks yes
that's right thank you
- so what did you yes so with with
natural ordering you you can do a retro
structure it's you know way is it really
outer break better with justice
because it improves feel low reference
what's it like afford the Tiki trees
projected or dimensions or something so
we the TV treatments are still you know
a higher dimension ever came up at the
national speaking to them for you to do
quits recursively go down and we that
really means that use that tree as
outrageous as I say okay
a similar for each person so that's a
separate
all right any other questions all right
well thanks again
yeah
can you say dr. Copelan mystery